AND THE MARKET WAY.
THE GRADE UPHILL SHOW IS COMING
UP.
>> I THINK YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER
A CHANGE AT THE TOP OF THE
TICKET WHEN SOMEONE IS ACTING
LIKE THIS.
HE IS AWAY TO HIS PERSONALITY SO
THE MINUTE YOU SAY SOMETHING HE
DOES NOT LIKE HE FIGURES THAT HE
CAN INTIMIDATE YOU LIKE A BULLY.
>> THERE IS AN EVIL AND TRYING
TO DIVIDE THE COUNTRY.
>> SO MANY BIG WORDS.
THE INVOLUNTARILY ALL MOUTH GUY
WHO SAW AS A NON-SERIOUS
BUTTHEAD IS NOW FINALLY BEING
TREATED AS A SERIOUS BUTTHEAD.
BECAUSE HE.
IT'S A STRANGE NEW RESPECT ROPE.
THE PEOPLE WHO CANNOT STAND YOU
WILL LAVISHED WITH ATTENTION
WANT YOU JUMP SHIP.
NOW HE IS ON CNN AND NBC BC WHO
TREAT HIM WITH ORACLE HELD
TOGETHER WITH HER JOB.
HE HOPES THAT ONE DAY HE WILL
END UP ON REAL HOUSEWIVES OF
CONEY ISLAND.
[LAUGHTER]
SO GOOD.
HE IS AMONG THE DESPERATE
ODDBALLS, THEY ROAM THE
COUNTRYSIDE AND THE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS THEY DEMEAN BECAUSE
THIS IS LESS ABOUT THE
ACCEPTANCE AND REJECTION OF
THEM.
HE IS BEST KNOWN FOR BEING CLOSE
TO PARK FOR 13 SECONDS BREAK
THAT IS A FACTOR.
AFTER ALL HE HAS NEVER CHANGED
IN THE LIMELIGHT FADING IN
STARDOM WAS SO DELICIOUS BUT HE
HAS MOVED ON, NOW HE WANTS TO
BUY GREENLAND.
THAT IS AWESOME.
AND IT IS NO SURPRISE HE IS A
REAL ESTATE GUY, HE WANTS TO BUY
IT SO HE CAN FLIP IT.
[LAUGHTER]
AS GRANITE COUNTERTOPS AND
SUBZERO FRIDGE, BATHROOM
ENTITIES, DONE.
IT LEAVES ME TOO WONDER, DO YOU
LOVE TRAINS OR TRUCKS?
>> I LOVE TRAINS AND TRUCKS OF
ALL EVEN WHEN I WAS A LITTLE BOY
AT FOUR YEARS OLD MY MOTHER
WOULD SAY I LOVE TRUCKS, I DO
NOT.
I STILL DO, NOTHING CHANGES.
SOMEDAY YOU MIGHT BECOME
PRESIDENT BUT NOTHING CHANGES.
I STILL LOVE TRUCKS.
>> NOTHING CHANGES BUT WHAT
ABOUT THE RAIN.
IT'S SO TRUE, HE SPEAKS THE
TRUTH ABOUT THE UMBRELLA AND
WHAT DO WE SEND THEM?
>> WE SEND THEM WHEAT.
IT'S NOT A GOOD DEAL.
AND THEY DON'T EVEN WANT OUR
WEEK.
THEY DO BECAUSE THEY WANT US TO
FEEL IT WERE OKAY.
THEY DO IT TO MAKE US FEEL GOOD.
>> ALL OF A SUDDEN IT STOPS THE
WIND AND THE TELEVISIONS GO OFF.
IN YOUR WIVES AND HUSBANDS SAY
DARLING, I WANT TO WATCH DONALD
TRUMP ON TELEVISION TONIGHT BUT
THE WIND STOPPED BLOWING AND I
CANNOT WATCH, NO ELECTRICITY IN
THE HOUSE.
>> REMEMBER WHEN THE CITY WOULD
BUILD LITTLE PIECES.
>> THE CITY USED TO BUILD LITTLE
PIECES OF THE PIECE THERE,
LITTLE PIECE HERE, A FEW YEARS
LATER A LITTLE PIECE HERE, AND
WHAT ABOUT YOUR CAMPAIGN MANAGER
I HEARD HE IS TALL.
>> HE IS NOW OUR CAMPAIGN
MANAGER AND HE'S ONE OF THE
TALLEST HUMAN BEINGS I'VE EVER
SEEN.
IT'S NICE WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE TO
LOOK FOR ANYBODY YOU JUST LOOK
OVER AND SEE A GUY TWICE AS TALL
AS EVERYBODY.
>> WHETHER YOU LOVE HIM OR HATE
HIM YOU HAVE TO VOTE FROM.
>> WHETHER YOU LOVE ME OR HATE
ME YOU HAVE TO VOTE FOR ME.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERING]
WHAT IS THE DEMOCRAT STRATEGY TO
BE BORING?
THURSDAY CLAIMS WHAT PEOPLE WANT
IS OPPOSITE OF TRUMP SOMEONE NOT
SO EXHAUSTING WHO DOES NOT FORCE
YOU TO THINK CONSTANTLY ABOUT
POLITICS.
I GET IT, PROMISING SERENITY IS
PERSUASIVE GOING FROM TRUMP TO
BIDEN IS LIKE PUTTING ON A
COMPANY'S WATER AFTER A WEEKEND
OF WEARING NOTHING BUT LEATHER
CHAPS.
[LAUGHTER]
I KNOW THAT FEELING.
BUT IT'S BS.
REMEMBER THESE ARE THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO MADE POLITICS
PERSONAL AND FAILED OUT OF.
NOW THEY ARE TIRED OF POLITICS
INTERFERING WITH THEIR GLOOMY
PERSONAL LIVES.
SCREW YOU, NOW YOU KNOW HOW WE
FELT SINCE THE 1960s, THEY
HAVE BEEN INJECTING POLITICS
INTO EVERYTHING, SPORTS, MOVIES,
BEDROOMS.
USE THIS DRAW YOU TURTLES.
WORK OUT AT EQUINOX.
YOU ARE OBVIOUSLY FAKING.
SO THIS TRUMP IS SO EXHAUSTING
IS JUST BS.
BASED ON THE FACT THAT THE BS
THERE'S FINALLY HAVE RELOCKED
THE POSITION.
IT'S LIKE WHEN THEY TALK
POLARIZATION, THAT'S CODE FOR
THE GOOD OLD DAYS WHEN THERE WAS
ONE SIDE.
POLARIZATION REQUIRES AN
ADVERSARY AND BEFORE TRUMP
REPUBLICANS DID NOT HAVE ONE
THAT COULD BE THE UGLINESS
COMING FROM THE OTHER SIDE.
BEFORE TRUMP'S THEY COULD CRAB
ON YOU DAY AND NIGHT.
NOW THE REPUBLICANS HAVE A APPLE
CANYON AND IT AIN'T NEVER GOING
TO STOP SHOOTING CRAB AT THEM.
OF COURSE NOW THEY WANT NORMALCY
AS THEY INTENSIFY THEIR OWN
CAMPAIGN AND THEY KEEP WIDENING
THE TARGET.
IT IS NOT TRUMP WHO IS THE
PROBLEM IS THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM
AND HIS FAMILY AND THE PEOPLE
THAT VOTED FOR HIM AND DID NOT
VOTE FOR HIM AND THE PEOPLE WHO
WATCH THEM ON TV AND DON'T FOAM
AT THE MOUTH WHEN HE IS
MENTIONED IN THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT ACTIVELY RESISTING HIM.
IT'S A RACE WAR, THE LEFT
PUNISHES HALF OF THE POPULATION
BY TARGETING, SMEARING ANY
BUSINESSES THAT MIGHT EMPLOY
ANYONE WHO WOULD SUPPORT TRUMP.
ONE WONDERS HOW FAR THIS COULD
GO.
>> WHAT DO YOU NEED?
>> MACADAMIA NUTS, THEY ARE
GROWN IN HAWAII, YOU KNOW WHAT
ELSE IS IN HAWAII AT TRUMP
INTERNATIONAL HOTEL.
HAWAII DIRECTLY BENEFITS FROM
THE HOTEL.
NO I WILL NOT BE HAVING ANY OF
YOUR MACADAMIA.
IS THAT A FAIR SHARE?
>> FAVORITE TEAM.
>> WOW.
>> FLYERS IN PHILADELPHIA?
IT'S IN PENNSYLVANIA ESTATE
TRUMP ONE IN 2016 NICE WHITE
SUPREMACY.
>> YOU MEAN LIKE CAPTAIN
AMERICAN ACTION FIGURE, HUMANE
MARBLES CAPTAIN MORGAN ACTION
FIGURE THE SAME CEO GAVE MONEY
TO DONALD TRUMP THIS YEAR.
>> WHAT IS THAT A BANDANNA?
>> NICE BANDANNA JUST LIKE THE
ONE WORN BY BRET MICHAELS AND
CELEBRITY APPRENTICE HOSTED BY
DONALD TRUMP RATE WHAT ABOUT
YOUR SHOES?
AREN'T THOSE THE SAME SHOES THAT
WERE ON 49th STREET BETWEEN
FIFTH AND SIXTH AVENUE WHERE
SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE IS FILMED,
THE SAME SNL WHO GAVE DONALD
TRUMP A PLATFORM BY LETTING HIM
HOST THE SHOW TWICE.
WHAT ABOUT YOUR 5-YEAR-OLD
DRAWINGS, THE USED CRAYOLA
CROWNS OWNED BY HALLMARK WHICH
OWNS HALLMARK CHANNEL WHICH
AIRED A FILM BROADCASTING
CHRISTMAS WITH ED TRUMP
SUPPORTED DEAN CAIN.
HOW DARE YOU.
IS THAT KILT?
YOU KNOW TRUMP'S MOTHER IS
SCOTTISH.
[LAUGHTER]
>> FINE.
>> ARE WE GOOD UNTIL THURSDAY?
>> THANKS TRUMP.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERING]
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUEST.
AUTHOR AND POLITICAL COMMENTATOR
MARK STEIN.
[APPLAUSE]
EVEN HIS ATTACK WILL MAKE YOU
LAUGH.
JOE MACKIE.
>> SHE IS FUNNY SMART, CAT TIP.
>> AND IF YOU BORROW IN HIS
FOOTSTEPS HE MAY NEED A LADDER
TO GET OUT,.
[CHEERING]
RECOVERED A LOT, FEEL FREE TO
COMMENT ON ANYTHING WHAT ABOUT
SECURE MUJI, GREENLAND, THE
TRADE WAR AGAINST AMERICANS BY
AMERICANS,.
>> I'M GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
PRE-CREDIT, I HAVE NEVER SEEN
RACHEL MADDOW TELLING A JOKE
BEFORE.
[LAUGHTER]
SHE HAS THE WHOLE HILLARY BOBBLE
HEAD WHEN HILLARY TELLS A JOKE.
SHE HAS THE HILLARY -- AND WHAT
WAS SHE SAYING, TRUMP WANTS TO
BUY GREENLAND SO HE CAN BE THE
KING.
THIS IS WHY ALL THE
PROFESSIONALS CALL IT.
THAT IS WHY THEY'RE SO EXHAUSTED
BY TRUMP.
AND THEY ARE NOT DISCIPLINE TO
BE BORN.
WHEN THEY SAY MAKE AMERICA
BUOYANT AGAIN, AS YOU SAY FOR
DECADES THEY'VE INSISTED THEIR
GUYS ARE FASCINATING.
LIKE CLINTON, OBAMA, EVEN AL
GORE THEY PUT HIM ON THE COVER
OF VANITY FAIR, VOGUE, "ROLLING
STONE", THEY PRETEND THEY ARE
CELEBRITIES.
IN THE EVEN PUT ON THE COVER OF
VANITY FAIR.
HE THINKS INSTAGRAM MEAN HIMSELF
IS INTERESTING.
THAT IS THE POINT ABOUT
POLITICS.
THEY DID BORING THINGS BUT THE
MEDIA REPRESENTED AS GLAMOROUS.
SO BETO O'ROURKE IS GLAMOROUS.
IN A WAY THAT BOB DOLE'S HAIR IS
NOT.
EVEN THOUGH I WOULD BET HE HAS A
LOT MORE.
[LAUGHTER]
SO I THINK IT TAKES INTENSE GUTS
ENCOURAGED TO HAVE THE
CONVICTION OF YOUR OWN BORING
US.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE
INTEGRITY TO BE AS COMPLETELY
BORING AS THEY SHOULD BE.
I AM GOING TO TRY IT FOR THE
REST OF THE SHOW.
[LAUGHTER]
IS GOING QUITE WELL SO FAR.
>> YOU HAVE A HEAD START.
JOE WHAT ARE YOU EXCITED ABOUT?
GREENLAND, ANYTHING?
>> IT HAS BEEN A ROLLER COASTER
FOR GREENLAND BECAUSE IF YOU
READ WHAT HE ACTUALLY SAID HE
WAS IN A MEETING AND SAID
DENMARK IS HAVING A LOT OF
TROUBLE WITH HOW MUCH IF THE
SPEND AND SOMEONE SAID YOU
SHOULD BUY IT AND HE SAID IS
THAT EVEN POSSIBLE, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
IT'S NO POINT THAT HE WAS GOING
TO BUY IT BUT PEOPLE WERE
OFFENDED AT THE IDEA THAT
AMERICA WANTED TO BUY THEM.
YOU SHOULD BE SO LUCKY.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
THERE'S SUCH A CONSENSUS AMONG
DEMOCRATS THAT WHAT THEY NEED TO
BEAT DONALD TRUMP IS BORING
CANDIDATE.
IF THAT WERE THE CASE HILLARY
CLINTON WOULD HAVE ONE IN 2016.
SHE IS BORING AND ACTUALLY
IMPRESSIVE THAT SHE MANAGES TO
BE SO BORING.
USUALLY PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF INVOLVED CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION ARE AT LEAST A
LITTLE BIT EXCITING.
[LAUGHTER]
SHE IS THE MOST BORING CRIMINAL
EVER.
LIKE I HAVE EATEN RICE CAKES
WITH MORE PIZZAZZ.
I JUST THINK THAT MAYBE THEY
SHOULD THINK ABOUT THAT BUT THEY
DON'T.
>> LAST WORD.
I HAVEN'T LAUGHED THIS HARD
SINCE I WAS A LITTLE SCHOOLGIRL.
I WITNESSED A LOT OF RACISM BUT
THIS WHITE RACIST STUFF IS
AWESOME.
WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT WHITE
PEOPLE.
THIS IS AMAZING, YOU TOO LITTLE
WHITE BOY IN THE TRUCK YOU BEEN
BOUGHT.
WE HAVE COME -- WE HAVE TO
BACKUP, WERE ABOUT TO BUY WHITE
PEOPLE.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU PUT A UNIQUE SPIN ON THIS.
>> THIS IS AWESOME, ALL WHITE
MEN --
>> GREENLAND.